i am going to throw to an interview
right now um with a guest
uh some people would call picture
perfect she's a photographer jillian
laub what i love about this conversation
is it's a lot of political views can
come under one roof
and how do we deal with that how do we
find our common ground how do we listen
to each other how do we accept each
other how do we have different
viewpoints all in one home
this is what's happening in our world
let alone country
and we find our way and uh jillian
documented her family's way and i can't
wait for you to take a look
jillian what gave you the idea to do
this book what was the inspiration what
was this
i have been photographing my family for
over 20 years and it was more of a
personal project i have a very colorful
family with lots of characters in that
you do
that's my grandfather on the cover i
love this cover i really do
so
it was really more of a personal project
and then in 2016
um there was a rift in our family and
and i you know i've always prided myself
on having the closest
family
and then in 2016 my parents
became passionate trump supporters and
um and like i do with all of my
photography i work my work helps me work
through
you know
what i'm going through personally
and i continued to photograph my family
and then i realized that my family was
really just a microcosm
of what so many families in america were
going through
and that's when i decided to make it a
book i mean i just think there's so much
great stuff going on in this photograph
politics aside
is your is that is that your mom that's
my mom is she meditating she was at the
um end of a yoga class and she's in
chavastnash so she is meditating perfect
okay in the next photograph may i say
yeah i love this one yeah and who is
this member of your face oh this is my
cousin violet and she's um the family
activist yeah and completely
in a 180 we've got the aoc the elizabeth
warren the obama that must be fun and
interesting at the dinner table
so she's a high school student here and
um when i made this portrait of her in
her bedroom i asked her you know how do
you feel are you
you know are you embarrassed are you
ashamed that you're going to be in a
book
with you know your trump supporting
loving family and she looked at me and
she's like
why why would i be
and she said
jillian like listen listen to what they
have to say you know they have an
opinion too and to me that was so
inspiring
so
i love i love this picture because she
represents that can we go to the next
photograph
okay there you go
that that pretty much says it all what
do you think when you look at this
photograph let alone when you took it
this gives me i i love this because this
is my mom with her best friend bonnie
who is like a second mom to me and to me
this really is just about the power of
friendship and um they had her they had
some tough moments in the past four
years
but um but they just love each other so
much and
and to them that was way more important
than anything else
i i love that so thank you for your keen
eye jillian thank you
i
embrace that we all have our differences
and i think discussing it or knowing
when to walk away whatever it is
to find our common ground is so much of
my life's mission so family matters
jillian's book and exhibition at the
international center of photography
which is by the way the big leagues
and
please check it out
[Music]